Canon folder and push them into the wall
with our country having started it
already in 2014 using the Army against
the civilian population and organizing
the genocide and blockade and Terror
against the people who refused who
refused to acknowledge the Ukrainian
power as a result of the military coup
they refused to have a peaceful solution
of resolving donbass problems and
started claiming the right to use of
nuclear weapons it became clear as
before the second time the large
um offensive or the donbass is even
inevitable
and the decision of the preemptive
military operation was the only decision
possible and absolutely necessary and
the main aim of freeing the whole of the
territory of donbass remains without
change they don't bust People's Republic
is almost fully cleared of the Nazis the
fights in the Donetsk People's Republic
continue and the occupation regime has
um made a deep line of defense and
therefore the parts of our army and
state donbass military units are using
the technology using the people and our
friend
People's Republic step by step three in
the towns and Villages and helping
people who were turned into
hostages by the key of regime as you
know the professional Army serving under
conduct are taking part in the special
military operation
however the volunteer units are fighting
alongside them they have different
nationalities professions and ages they
are true Patriots they are protecting
Russia and donbass upon the core of
their hearts in this regard the ministry
of defense was instructed by me in full
to determine as soon as possible the
legal status of those errors and also
the units of tanyetsk and luhansk
people's republics they have to be the
same as the professional military of the
Russian army including the social
guarantees medical and financial
supplies we need to pay special
attention to procurements for the units
of the donbas
by uh technology
entrepreneurships and our army based on
the decisions of the ministry of defense
and the general command have freed from
the new analysis the considerable
territories of Herson and zaporosia
regions as a result
there is a long line of military contact
over a thousand kilometers
and I want to say that publicly for the
first time after the start of the
special military operation also at the
Istanbul negotiations
there was a very positive reaction to
our proposals concerning ensuring the
security of Russia
but it was obvious that the West was not
happy with the peaceful decision so
after which in certain compromises they
effectively were given a direct
order to undermine the negotiations and
the key of regime started using new
bands of foreign mercenaries and
nationalists
and the Army trained by NATO standards
and actually commanded by the Western
Commanders
the repression regime intensified across
the whole of Ukraine against its own
citizens after the military coup in 2014
the politics of Terror and intimidation
against Russia becomes more and more
barbaric and terrible I want to stress
that most people living in the
territories freed from the neo-nazis and
first of all they are the navorrosia
historic lands we're talking about
regions
you have seen the barbarities of the
neo-nazis in the Region's captures by
them
the Banderas Banderas followers and the
Nazis
are torturing
um the peaceful citizens internet
people's republics
and hear some areas over seven and a
half million people lived before the
start of the military operation many of
them were forced to become refugees
those who are left are constantly
bombarded by artillery and Rocket
attacks on the part of The neo-nazis
Who attack hospitals and schools and
create acts of Terror against the
peaceful citizens
we have no moral rights to give people
this idea to us
to be
butchered and
um we need to give them a chance to
determine their own space the
parliaments of the DNR and the l r and
the administration's Carson and
zaparosia regions have decided to call
referendums on during in Russia and they
asked Russia to support such a step I
shall stress we will do all we can to
ensure safe conditions for holding the
referendums for people to be able to
express their will and decision in their
future that will be made by the citizens
of the DNR the Eleanor and zaporosia and
Herson regions will be supported by us
dear friends
today our army as I said
is acting at the military front line
exceeding a thousand kilometers and they
are facing not just the neo-nazis but
the whole military machine of the
collective West in this situation I deem
it's necessary to make the following
decision which is
um appropriate in full to the threat
we're facing
the defense of our motherland it's
sovereignty and territorial Integrity to
ensure the security of our people and in
the freed territories I think necessary
to support the proposal of the ministry
of defense and the general command
for partial mobilization held in the
Russian Federation I stress it is
partial mobilization
only those who are currently in reserve
will be conscripted
and also those who served in the Army
have certain military
um professions
and
will be
always
given additional military training taken
into account the special military
operation
the decree of partial mobilization has
been signed officially
the chambers of the federal
assembly and the state Juma will be
informed
the mobilization events shall start
today on the 21st of September
I task the health regions to provide all
the necessary assets
um assistance to the military
commissariats
I shall stress that Russian citizens
called up as a part of Mobile
mobilization will be given all the
guaranteed
guarantees all the benefits of those
serving under contract
degree of partial mobilization
encompasses additional measures too
defend the state procurement for defense
um concerning the military technology
and additional capacities for its
production or the financial matters
for supplying the defense factories
shall be resolved by the government
without delay
it's aggressive anti-russian policy the
West has crossed all lines we constantly
hear threats against our people
and some irresponsible politicians in
the west are speaking not just of the
plans of providing Ukraine with
long-range
um
the military systems that would be able
to hit the regions of Russia
that is already happening uh we're
talking about the Border areas including
Belgrade region and the systems using a
strategic drones
um
planes
doing reconnaissance across the whole of
the Russians South and there are plants
in Washington and Brussels to move their
military action onto the Russian
territory
they're not just talking about Russia
being completely destroyed a battlefield
talking about political cultural and all
the types of sovereignty with complete
pillage now they're talking about
nuclear
um
blackmails
the zaparosia nuclear power plant was
shelled and also some high positioned
representatives of leading NATO states
were saying that there might be
responsibility and
permissibility to use nuclear weapons
against Russia
those that allow such statements shall
be reminded that our country also has
various weapons of Destruction and with
regard to certain components they're
even more modern than the NATO ones and
if there is a threat to the territorial
Integrity of our country and for
protecting our people we will certainly
use all the means available to us and
I'm not bluffing
Russian citizens can be certain that the
territorial Integrity of our motherlands
our freedom and Independence shall be
secured I show stress by all means
available to us and they is trying to
Blackmail us with nuclear weapons should
know
that the tables can turn on them
in our historic tradition
our people had it in their Destiny to
stop those who are trying to
subjugate our motherland
and divided and we will do that now it
will happen I believe in your support
goodness some quotes there um from uh
President Putin reminding the West that
Russia has modern weapons of Destruction
he went on to say I'm not bluffing he
also talked about conscription for some
Russian citizens with military
um backgrounds Diana's been listening
goodness Diana good morning
hi Kay we'll take some uh listening to
that speech doesn't it he started off
once again you really feel his paranoia
his kind of persecution complex talking
all about how for a long time this has
been uh the Western effort to destroy
and undermine Russia explaining why his
special military operation has to
continue
um the kind of pressure uh that the
neo-nazis as he called them was exerting
on the people of Ukraine and the people
of historic novarecia that old word to
describe the regions that are now going
to be holding referendums aparicia
Carson Donetsk and luhansk and how
Russia was on the right course to
protect them
um but he needed to take various steps
which I think a lot of analysts were
anticipating that at some point he was
going to have to solve his Manpower
problem on the battlefield and he has
announced to partial mobilization of
Russia's Reserve forces so we don't know
exactly who but those who did do
military service you can do military
service here but there are exceptions so
I suppose those who did military service
will be called up that starts today the
referendums are going to be from Friday
until the following Tuesday four days of
voting and he gave a very Stark warning
at the end that
he would use nuclear weapons if the
sovereignty and territorial Integrity of
the country was threatened saying that
it was the West who had raised the
Specter of nuclear weapons they haven't
and saying that if they continued to
Blackmail Russia in nuclear with sort of
nuclear ways then they should be aware
that he would strike back talking about
the range of weapons that he has at his
disposal saying I am not bluffing
um very clear War morning there from
Vladimir Putin that he will escalate if
he deems it necessary trying to
reinforce to his people that what he is
doing is saving the people of donbass
from the terrible repressive regime as
he called it of Ukraine uh which he
always says is a proxy of the West and
to save the Russian people this was all
a sort of Messianic speech about how the
West is out to destroy Russia and what
he is doing is in the name of saving
Russia
um so we have partial mobilization now
and again that very strong threat that
he will use nuclear weapons if he deems
it necessary okay Diana for now we will
come back to you thanks so much indeed
lucky to have the foreign office
minister with us Jillian Keegan good
morning you're reminded that you were
listening to what he had to say yes yes
well it's quite obviously a worrying
escalation particularly the the last uh
comments there but uh and rather a
rewriting of History I think as well in
terms of uh what's happening in Ukraine
so let me be clear these the Putin's
lies and he's continuing to
um to completely misrepresent what's
happened in Ukraine it's an illegal war
in Ukraine it's Russia's a legal war in
Ukraine and of course we will still
stand by Ukraine as will all of all of
our NATO allies but yes some of the
language there was quite concerning at
the end and obviously we would urge for
calm our Gravely should we take his
threat that he's not bluffing about the
potential to use nuclear weapons well
clearly you know it's something that we
should take very seriously because you
know we're not in control I'm not sure
he's in control either really I mean
this is obviously an escalation and of
course to the Russian people now who
will be conscripted into this into this
war
um and it's hard to know what's going on
in Russia as well obviously they don't
have a free media like we can talk
freely here so that's that's also also
difficult but we've been very clear all
along and in fact the speech that the
Prime Minister will give today is going
to double down and say we will
absolutely continue to support Ukraine
and we will invest what we've already
put 2.3 billion pounds to supporting the
military aid in Ukraine and other Aid in
Ukraine and we'll do the same next year
to continue what's our message what's
the government's message to the people
of Ukraine this morning and also to the
people of Russia well the people of
Ukraine um you know it's it's the same
message we're there we're by your side
we will help us as much as we possibly
can they're incredibly Brave and of
course we've also seen that they've made
some significant progress in the last
couple of weeks and a few days indeed as
well which is probably prompted this
speech to the to the Russian people
um look beyond your own media it's very
very clear the whole global population
is very clear what's going on in Ukraine
we can all see what's going on in
Ukraine you know that there's lots and
lots of footage and in fact in isium
we've now seen some
um some war crimes some some evidence of
war crimes which is also why we've set
up the atrocity crimes Advisory Group to
try and make sure that we can help to
make sure that we capture that so there
are definitely war crimes and evidence
of sexual violence as well
I know that we only have a truncated
time with you this morning obviously
because of listening to President Putin
um why did Liz truss feel the need to go
to New York she's you know she's having
a bilateral face-to-face talks with
Biden she could have had that here and
there's no trade deal on the table
oh no I mean there's lots of world
leaders in New York in fact pretty much
lots of people who came here to go to
Her Majesty's funeral
um pretty much all of them went uh on on
the plane there's lots of things to be
discussed there's lots of bilaterals
that will be taking place obviously